This morning.
Tokyo's Haneda
airport
expected to cancel more than 100 flights
after that
tragic collision
between a Japan Airlines
jet and a Japanese Coast Guard
plane on Tuesday,
killing five crew members on the Coast
Guard flight.
Also, newly released audio reveals
that air traffic control
had cleared the commercial flight to land
just before the two planes collided.
Joining us now is CNN's
Will Ripley live from Tokyo.
And Will,
what more have we learned of that audio
from air traffic control?
So we know
from the transport ministry
they've released the official transcript
of what happened
during those crucial 4 minutes
from 5:43 p.m.
local time to 5:47 p.m..
During those 4 minutes,
the Coast Guard
turboprop aircraft
was taxiing on the runway, one runway
getting ready to take off.
At the same time,
the Japan airliner
was making its final descent into Haneda.
Listen now to the instructions
that were given.
First, you're going to hear
from the commercial flight
to air traffic control
and then you're going
to hear the instructions
that air traffic control gave
to that Coast Guard plane,
to a private company.
Because this has been amazing
to have someone
every day with a number one,
I think a one of people.
So that is the recording from the air
traffic control side.
You know,
the Japan airliner had the all clear
to land on runway C
and the Coast Guard plane
was told to proceed to the holding point,
basically stay in place
and stay there
until it's time for you to take off.
But, of course,
we know that the Coast Guard plane
was actually right
in the path of the Japan airliner
as it was landing
when the two planes hit.
There was that massive fireball.
And of course, we know what happened.
Yet at least five of the Coast
Guard crew members were killed
and everybody on board
the plane was able to evacuate
with just seconds to spare.
But the crucial question,
did the Coast Guard pilot
not know where he was
or did air
traffic control
not know the actual location of the plane
when they said to hold point?
And why did none of the three pilots
in the cockpit of the Japan
of the Japanese airliner
not see that
there was a plane
in the runway right in their path
and abort the landing?
They have not found the cockpit voice
recorder for the commercial plane.
It's still sitting
right there in the middle of the runway,
a pile of metal and plastic.
They have located
the cockpit voice recorder
for the Coast Guard aircraft.
So those are going to be
the crucial questions
as they search for more answers
as to how all of this happened.
Well, Japan Airlines also said
the in-flight system malfunctioned.
I think what they said
during an evacuation of the passengers,
the crew was actually using a megaphone
to communicate.
Well, what are we learning about this?
Yeah, we're getting
some really interesting
new video, eyewitness video
from inside the plane
during those crucial seconds.
And a lot of things
were actually going wrong.
Some of the exit doors
passengers say were not operational.
And, yes, as you
mentioned,
the communication system of the plane
was not working,
which meant that the flight attendants
had to basically pull out the megaphones
and shout to get everybody off the plane.
Well,
there was a lot of other
things happening.
And take a look at this
from
what this video shows us is that, yes,
it was chaotic.
There was black smoke filling the cabin.
The flames were getting closer.
They were just outside the windows.
People didn't
grab for their carry on bags.
There was no arguing
or pushing and shouting.
People just listen to the instructions
and they got off the plane safely.
All of them did.
It's a lesson for anyone
who travels and flies on planes
to look at very closely, guys.